yeah welcome to this video yeah at the
moment this one are not not one more
than one interesting tournament going on
think them maybe most interesting one is
the world junior championships it's
always interesting to to look at the the
young players but the most get the
highest-profile tournament certainly am
at the moment is the russian
championships which is some yeah
obviously the strongest national
championships in the world and it's got
them almost all Russian top players I
think Kramnik and tomorrow's which are
missing but otherwise and they're all
there um get played immediately before
the Chess Olympiad which is we'll be
starting in two weeks and I don't know
maybe this is one reason why this
tournament um has seen so many drawers
it's a rather dull affair I must submit
um before the last round which is played
just at the moment today on their six
players leading with plus 1 so 1 win
restaurateur two wins and one loss yeah
there haven't been so many interesting
games but yesterday I'm there was a very
sharp battle between the defending
champion grandma's Peter swidler from
st. Petersburg and grandmaster Nikita
with Hugh Gough I'm not quite sure I
think he's from Moscow but not one
hundred percent sure which you officer
not so well known maybe it's one of the
better of the best young russian GM's
already above 2,700 of course swindler
doesn't need any introduction he's a
six-time Russian champion I'm not sure
if this is the record of maybe I don't
know what we need 17 times or something
but if it isn't the record it's close to
it yeah let's check out this game a very
interesting battle sweetland plane efore
sem usually does
and with you go from response response e
6 um yeah here's some a regular French
player with you go he even published a
book on the French defense and which is
quite nice actually and there are two
books even he published one island about
two years ago and there has been a
second edition of this which is really
nicely improved alright so the French it
is and swollen oops usually this was a
bit quick usually play some 93 at this
point which is arguably the main move he
M even did that one round before against
Potkin but didn't really get so much and
in this game we decided to play a five
the advanced variation maybe I'm just
slight surprise to which you go if I
don't think villa is playing that
usually but sweet let some known to be a
good friend of Alexander Greece oaks and
Grigio get some may be the world's
leading expert on the advance so maybe
Dave they did some analyzing work on on
similar to together so okay we got the
normal kind of move c5 c3 and with you
half now place Queen b6 which can have
independent significance of Blackboard
play now Bishop to d7 with this kind of
idea but it didn't go for this he just
played 96 and somewhat to cook here you
just played 96 I'm just posing to them
yeah main variation of the advanced
french there's also the similar position
of black instead of Queen B six plays
Bishop d7 which is said the other main
line I'm Sweden or place a 3 which is
some the main line by far nowadays I'm
alternatives are Bishop e2
on the old book we should be three but
Bishop d3 is usually connected with the
pawn sacrifice this kind of stuff which
nowadays is considered to be simply yeah
yeah close to incorrect black can just
take the pawn and doesn't have fun so
many problems so Bishop d3 is some
pretty much out of the picture nowadays
on top level which should be to as
possible but this gives some black
somewhat better counter play than a
three so I three is the main move yeah
hip like has some number of options you
can go from of this completely closed
though approach closing the Queen side
and playing with moves like Knight a5
and trying to prepare such a maneuver we
should be seven a form of course at the
moment this bishop would be hanging but
you can prepare all this so this would
be a very long maneuvering battle but of
course the c-4 move doesn't really am
put any pressure on the center so it's
not a move that I'd like to play must
admit her like more to put pressure on
the center maybe the main move from
nowadays is nigh to h6 and what with
YouGov place is rather similar night to
h6 can continue in this fashion before
it takes takes Knight a5 this is maybe
the main line which you have placed like
g2e 7 which um has the same idea
possibly but it divides any kinds of
captures on age 6 which is an option for
white so 97 is interesting but it has a
drawback which swidler immediately tries
to exploit if he would play b form we
would most like him get a simple
transposition but will have played them
something else he took on c5 which must
be the natural drawback of 97 because
now the
snide obstructs the bishop it cannot
take and yeah if Blackwood would retake
now on c5 when I think I'm why should
get a nice position it doesn't make so
much sense to put the green out so early
the queen is not very well positioned on
c5 as it doesn't put any pressure on e5
and this is maybe some slightly better
for white if you look at this protecting
you five and then white maybe em even
can think about a quick advance of the
age porn it's simply that there's not
enough pressure on only five here so
with you I've had to head down had a
different idea he just played Quincy
which I like attacking e5 and Sevilla
protected now this pawn with Bishop b5
using the spin of the of the night with
a move like Bishop f4 like I'm playing a
g6 attacking the bishop and also taking
this pawn and yeah this is already a bit
uncomfortable for white it's not like
his worse but black is certainly okay
here he's got the bishop now nicely
positioned and d5 a sum upon which you
can really put pressure on it's much
better to have the bishop here then then
then the Queen so this is why we should
be five was played um yeah now just
Bishop d7 I'm attacking the e5 pawn
again and Swilley protected with the
Queen and now f6 which is a very sharp
move but yeah of course very much in
spirit of the position like has
sacrificed this Pony on c5 but he's
trying to go for central dominance and
so you can see it quickly leads to a
really complicated position like had a
no-talent if he could have played them
just simply 96a taking the spawn again
and they don't think white shut down
should have any big advantage on for
instance if white now covers this pawn
like an can take here and I don't think
you should have any any big problems
okay but he played f6 which is a much
sharper yeah why doesn't have much
alternative see he captured on f6 cannot
keep the pawn down g tags f and now wide
plate night B to D to developing this
piece here was also possible to just
castle but then it's understandable that
castles is a move at you yeah I want to
think twice about black is very ready to
to use the g file with rook g8 of course
it will castle long probably now let's
just cancel long and yeah black has
ideas rook g85 Bishop g4 I think black
has a nice active position here I really
like it I'm not quite sure I think
all-in-all this idea with f6 it's very
sharp but also promising idea for black
it looks like you get that get active
play so in the game he is decided to
postpone canceling and play a night BD
to which has some the possible idea to
play Knight be three at some point to
Kevin c5 yep like now when term for long
cancels and white plate c4 which was
also of course an idea of night BTW too
so we text the center and like simply
plays rook g8 attacking the pawn yeah
and now we've got this this issue again
do you want to castle into this on what
else to play the pawn is just hanging
you cannot really allow like to take it
and if you look at this castles and e5
and black is immediately ready to fly
bish of age three let's say something
like this here
covering the spawn at least and then
here may you hear you even need to go to
play move like 91 and I think black gum
has a nice active position nothing much
to complain about you of course you
sacrifice a pawn but it's um it's very
active so castles were also certainly
different difficult decision to to make
you play g3 covering the Jeep one this
way and we lighten up lady five so
advancing in the center and getting this
Bishop out which can play a big role on
edge free also so here on 83 on g4 or
the light squares a weakened and you
will see in the game that this is really
the main point um okay so wyd now I'm
captured on d5 Knight takes and lie to
be three um just quickly if white were
to try to protect the c5 phone would be
four then like immediately wins with
this this night move and yeah what would
should why do we get something along
these lines and now you see that the
light squares are a huge problem night c
2 is threatened end this kind of this
kind of stuff gets very ugly very
quickly and black is completely tied
down why does snow white of course why
does completely tied down here yeah this
is not a playable at all this be formed
so he covered this with them with an ID
yam black plate the logical move Bishop
to g4 setting up this pin and Sevilla of
course them immediately wants to escape
this pin
a very annoying feature of the position
does this pin black might even play fo
at some point provoking wider to take
with the Queen and then rookie aided and
at the proper moment so it's a very very
unfortunate configuration here with
queen and king on the e-file and this
pin so this villa tries to use a
technical trick to get rid of this he
plays some Queen to see to the idea
being of black knock captures on f3 so
and you've got this check in and went
back the bishop black could have played
this wouldn't have been wouldn't have
been bad something like this and now
maybe this move um probably leads to ya
round equal position but in this
position here after foodless tricky
quincy to black has a much better move
which he played this is a very strong
move Knight f form yeah and what what is
this move doing it is yeah breaking the
connection between the f3 and the f55
square so if white would take the night
now then black simply captures on f3 and
this Czechia on f5 now it's really
nothing much in this position now the
rook h1 is hanging and black you're
threatening also rook do you want
checkmate so why can actually resign
here um yeah taking the night just loses
the game the same applies for for this
kind of stuff there you can / should be
saying so I'm very nice move which white
cannot take and okay if you cannot take
this piece it's obviously am quite
annoying so what should why do the night
is hanging now on f3 and you need to
move it you have no real way to to cover
it so okay let's say you can cover its
middle up late night be too
d 2 but what what are alternatives let's
say a white will move it move it away
then you need to deal with this kind of
stuff check here threatening huge
discoveries and you need to play then
this move and well black for pong has
gotten ormus compensation White's pieces
are completely yeah I awfully placed and
I think it should be close to winning
for black alright so what should why do
this light is hanging he played night
bd2 and in this position on black has a
very strong move which she would she
found like played a really great game
here he captured on YouTube and this now
is some is very strong what should
should why do of course you need to
recapture but also the night is hanging
he needs to play 1962 sweedler did this
so but let's check quickly what what out
some is possible simple is some is this
move then black simply take the night
off rook is hanging 94 threatening so
this is very easy you cannot take take
them the same applies for this it's
pretty much the same and well okay you
can Kingda to i think is yep it's all
the same white needs to take with the
night which you did and then this the
the idea behind this exchange zach is
revealed like it's got 94 with the tempo
and now you see black has got to two
nights on d find f for the bishop and
well white skin looks really really ugly
in a crossfire of black's pieces
so when it's obviously very very
dangerous for white white plate go into
a form yeah and in this position on
black has a number of good possibilities
there was one very strong possibility
which she overlooked but which is
completely understandable he played and
we should take C Phi which is okay it's
not it's not spoiling much like still is
better after this move but he had a very
strong possibility giving this check
here he certainly considered this I mean
this is the first move you look at
giving a check but then the the point is
king f1 and Bishop bone to h3 now this
all kinds of discoveries are threatened
but then the discoveries are just the
check at the moment I think the the
point that he missed here is the
following let's say B Form 93 check
kingi one and now black has an amazing
move go into c6 yeah this is a move that
you really should let's sink in for a
while it's really great just threatening
a direct checkmate on g2 and if white
capture c6 you've got this very
beautiful checkmater delivered by name
by the minor pieces it's even this
Bishop is even superfluous for this for
this made the two nights also would
deliver mate on their own so black can
afford to offer the Queen here and it's
even now it's even nicer f3 blacks got
the very strong move I'm sorry night
reform and
threatening to need another maid again
so what should why do it it's really
really nice you are I really cannot do
much if he takes for instance then
there's this move coming threatening
another mate and yeah this is actually
the end of the game white can only only
take the Queen now the law made on or
play something like this here check me
and this is a crossfire made of the
bishops yeah very nice but okay he
certainly missed this Queen c6 idea it's
very understandable not so much time on
the clock but what he played is
perfectly okay it's just not dumb not so
forceful he took on c5 and this is
certainly is a human move to play he
gets this piece and to play and the
thing is um it's no big deal if white
takes the night he did this
understandably you need to have some
material for you for your suffering and
alternatives didn't really help much he
took on a phone white and black
recaptured so it's a complete rook
sacrifice now but um of course black has
those huge threats here Queenie five
check or queen Queen e7 check checks on
the e-file and then White's king will be
mated this is why white needs to attend
to this and he played 90 form of course
them it's not a move you would you love
to make because it allows the piece
again to enter on f3 I'm in fact this is
what like played he played them
songwriter a three check and hear you
had a rather simple win I'm not quite
sure why I didn't play it I think this
is really a relatively easy to find
it could have played Queenie seven
attacking the the night and if white
retreats the bishop here to cover the
night you can just attack it with f5 and
black is relatively easy winning you
just get this night back only form and
then it's it's just a deadly attack for
foreign exchange I'm not quite sure I
think this would was rather easy to find
not quite sure what what he didn't like
about this um yeah hard to tell I this
this was winning but it's good that he
didn't do it really because we see some
really nice lines later so he went for
this check Knight f3 check and why
played king of one yeah there wasn't
really much much else king d 1 for
example um just um gets onto the rookie
eight and where would you go something
like King c2 and lines like these are
not much fun as well white simply will
lose some decisive material or get mated
so on he needed to go to f1 yeah now
black gave this check here King it to
only move xiety fall back and King e1
and yeah in this position it's rather
similar to the position before here
again Queenie seven would have won it's
basically the same position as before
now the bishop is on age three instead
of G formant it's still winning but he
didn't do this somehow this idea yeah he
didn't didn't really am had in mind um
he played
Bishop g2 with wood doesn't look bad at
all certainly need to look at the clock
times sweet lad 13 minutes left and he
spent like spent the last couple of
minutes to play this move and he was
down too yeah the clock he honors his
seat us 27 seconds but need to be am a
bit bit skeptical if if this is really
really correct but he was certainly a
very low on time but Bishop g2 allows
why to probably escaped but it's super
difficult swidler played Quincy form
attacking the rook and the bishop here
most likely as say most likely because I
didn't do hours of analysis but this
move probably draws taking on c5 gender
it looks terrible for white but probably
this um this might jump me to draw at
least I didn't find anything and of
course assisted by by an engine it done
it should lead to draw at the end funny
enough from you if you look at this
white can you at once here and and even
survive this kind of wrong this kind of
stuff of course for a human um it's
nothing you'd like to do cha-cha-cha
yeah and them it's a draw by perpetual
check so night xe5 probably draws but
yeah a very very tough decision and
Quincy for looks pretty natural as well
yeah we chew off now plate rook 2d eight
and
this is this strong move really i'm a
very neat line now happens if white
would take with the Queen then like just
takes one check and now very nice f3
with the pawn it's a checkmate it's a
very cool mating mating configuration
where the rook takes all the PA other
squares on the default the night the
ones on the e farm and the bishop and
tick-borne are responsible for the last
swear CSL our pieces are involved in
them the mate it's very nice so white
couldn't take on c5 with the Queen and
so what should I do it's of course the
terrible position to to face he am
decided to take on c5 and and here black
gum decided to go for Knight f3 check he
was right down down on time but he
gained a couple of seconds here I guess
they play with increment Knight f3 check
and now you can I can show you how the
game ended really with zaida 3 check um
kingi to check again gimme one night a
few check and they agree to draw just
repeating moves but now here comes some
come to the catch black in this position
while Knight f3 was mostly drawn could
play to win a 5 check and not sure what
he what he missed about this about this
move because it said it's not really so
difficult um because I think you need to
see one thing here and this is the
following before Queen takes before
Queen TX b5 check some ink and it is
made again which we saw before and he
certainly saw this motif because he
played this rook da move here earlier
this rook t8 oops yeah for slightly
Leahey & animation I'm not sure this
this is made i shot this before check me
it's basically the same and with root d8
he sort of signals that he that he saw
this but down funny enough so here this
arena 5 it's basically the same idea and
white simply has the Queen detect and he
has no way to go if you if you move it
let's say here it's just a simple made
and what else is there you can move it
here because the night protects the
queen but then it's at this simply and
the Queen gets lost and black is winning
really easily so Queen a fiver would
have would have won the game mm-hmm
because so now what oops what else is
there i mean this is this is just the
same as before same major me yeah it's
always the same kind of idea so Queen f5
was winning and let's mention he played
this now comes the cash they repeated
this position three times and then it
was a draw here um white head two times
had the possibility but this is of
course completely insane had the
possibility to play king d 1 and this
actually seems to draw the game it's it
of course a completely insane decision
to play king d 1 but this is simply what
happens if you analyze this games with
computers they sometimes show you
resources which you simply wouldn't
think of in the game
so it's nothing do you have to blame
white for that he didn't took the chance
to escape kingdom with King d1 um yeah
it's funny I'm the possibly on best line
for black is supposed to be Bishop to g5
and of course there are many other
possibilities and then Bishop takes a
form with the idea being Queen takes
check and well this is this is just
insane no no sane person would think
about this line and hear why this even
in exchange at but his King is under so
much pressure that he will need he needs
to return some material and it will end
in a pretty draw position but of course
this is simply inhuman to to play kingly
one um yeah but I think for black gun
that he didn't seek Queen a 5-3 times of
the bid weird because he really saw the
idea obviously with this mate but not
not quite sure I just want to show it
quickly again here this Queen a fine
idea I'm not sure this is relatively
simple yeah and yeah this was one of the
drawers in this championships them
obviously one of the more exciting
drawers and yeah I hope you enjoy it
it's a pretty pretty interesting game
and also um maybe an idea for for black
players play the French the French
defense to look at this night geez have
an idea it seems that um possibly young
why doesn't have much much else to to
play a before in this position to
transpose into the normal lines but you
avoid all this Bishop takes h6 business
and this is what what's really played in
the game seems to lead to interesting
play for black
and this kind of position with woody
five suddenly I'm very attractive for
black get nice active possibilities
against whites King yeah thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it let's
talk soon with new videos